why are you the only man who wants to  stay with me  mm-hmm  thank you too  i do  why is mom so different around other  i  people  this is who she is  [Applause]  you love me  of course  you're not born  the fact that she's comfortable floating  all these relationships around all of us  you're better than it  she's different  that's what i like about her  i just want to feel joy in my life  you want to tell me why you didn't come  home last night not really  this isn't a game melinda  it's always been a game  [Music]  [Applause]  the truth is  if you were married to anyone else  you'd be so bored  if you kill yourself  do you think we'll ever be just happy  god i hope so  [Music]  you